- [Instructor] Let's say I have
a bag of colored balls here
and we know that 40% of
the balls are orange.
Now, imagine defining a random variable x.
And x is based on a trial
where we stick our hand in this bag,
we don't look around, and
we randomly pick a ball,
look at its color, we record it,
and then we're gonna put it back.
So we're gonna assume that
we have our placement here,
and we're gonna say that
our random variable x
is going to be equal to one
if we pick an orange ball
and it's going to be
equal to zero otherwise.
You might already recognize this
as a Bernoulli random variable.
And we can construct a
probability distribution for x.
In fact, let's do this.
So, x is going to be discrete.
It can only take on two different values.
So x can take on zero
or it can take on one,
and if 40% of the balls are orange,
the one has a 40% chance of happening,
so let me do that.
So there's gonna be 40%
chance of getting a one.
So, that's 0.4 right over there.
And there would be a 60%
chance or 0.6 probability
of getting a zero.
So this right over here,
just trying to hand-draw it.
So this would be 0.6
probability of getting a zero.
So we can call this the
probability distribution,
probability distribution for x.
This is all review so far,
but the reason why I did this
is because we're now
going to introduce ourself
to the notion of a sampling distribution.
And it can be a little bit
confusing because in our brain,
we tend to think in terms
of probability distributions
and not as much in terms
of sampling distributions.
So what you do in a sampling distribution
is you still start with a population here,
but then you take a
sample of that population.
Let me label things.
So this is our population.
This is our population here.
We take a sample
from the population,
and it could have a certain sample size,
sample size n.
And then we'll calculate some
statistic for that sample,
so we will calculate the statistic.
And then we're gonna think
about the distributions
of the statistics that we
can get from these samples.
So one way to think about
this is keep doing this.
So this is our first
sample of sample size n,
we calculate the statistics.
Then we take another
sample of sample size n
and then we calculate the statistic again.
And then we take another sample
and we just keep doing this.
We take another sample of sample size n
and we calculate the statistic again.
And let's say we were to do
this an infinite number of times
and we were to plot the
distribution of the statistic
that we're calculating.
Well then, we have our
sampling distribution.
Let's try to make this a
little bit more tangible
by going back to our colored
balls example, and calculate
or think about a sampling
distribution for that.
So let's say we have our population here
and we know that a parameter
for this population,
we know that the proportion
of balls that are orange.
40% are orange.
We don't always know the parameters.
Oftentimes, we're
estimating the parameters
by looking at samples.
But let's say we then
take sample sizes of 10.
So, sample size 10,
and every time we calculate
the statistic for our sample
of what percentage are orange.
So let's say the first
time we take a sample,
this time over here, we get three oranges.
Let's say the next time
we get two oranges.
Actually, let me do these as a proportion.
So if my sample size is
10, I get three oranges,
which is 30%.
And then if I do it
again, I get two oranges,
and that is 20%.
And I just keep doing this.
And eventually, I can plot a distribution
of these sample proportions.
You would end up with some type
of a discrete distribution.
And the way to read this
discrete distribution
is let's say this right over here ends up,
and I'm just gonna make up a number,
this isn't going to be the actual number,
but let's say that this is 0.15.
The way to read that is
you have a 15% chance
of getting a sample where
50% of your balls are orange
or if this right over here is 0.07,
that would mean that you have a 7% chance
where 20% of your balls are orange.
Now, to make this even a
little bit more tangible,
let's run a simulation
that actually does this.
This right over here is a simulation
created on Khan Academy,
on our computer programming
scratchpads by Charlotte Auen.
It's a simulation to construct
a sampling distribution.
So here, she's using candies
instead of just colored balls
but these candies are
essentially colored balls.
And so here, we can set
the population proportion.
So let's say that the actual proportion
as we saw on our example
of, let's say it's green
as opposed to orange here, is 40%.
And so let's say in each sample,
just as we said, our sample size is 10,
so we'll just take a sample size of 10.
And let's just do one sample first,
so let's just draw a sample.
And so what we did is we
took 10 of these gumballs out
and we are counting how
many of them are green.
So in this first sample of 10,
we see that one, two, three,
four, five, six of them are green.
So out of the possible outcomes,
we're now gonna tally one of our outcomes
having hey, we got six
of our 10 to be green.
And if we wanna show the proportion
instead of just the count,
we can just pick percentage here.
And so here, we've had
one scenario already
where 60% were green.
But we don't wanna just do one sample.
We just wanna keep drawing sample.
So let's draw another sample.
So in this last sample, 50% are green.
And so now that we have one was 50% green,
one was 60% green.
Let's draw another sample.
Now we have another sample
where we got 60% green,
so there are two situations
where we had 60% green.
And so I can keep doing
this over and over and over,
and so what we're creating right over here
is a sampling distribution.
And if we were to do this
an infinite number of times,
we would get the true
sampling distribution
of the sample proportion
given the actual population
proportion that is green.
And so, this is after 77 samples.
Notice, this is saying that
out of 77 of our samples,
22 of those samples
resulted in 40% of our
gumballs being green.
Only one of our samples
had 80% of our gumballs being green.
And if we just wanna
do a ton more samples,
I'll go all the way to
drawing 50 samples at a time.
So let me just keep increasing this.
Notice, we have 17 samples now
where we had zero percent that are green.
We have 91 of the 2200 samples
where 10% were green,
where one out of the 10
in our sample were green.
Now we could convert any of
these number, 17 and 91, 256,
we could turn these into percentages
by just dividing by the number of samples.
But this is fun, we could just keep going
and making this larger
and larger and larger.
I encourage you to play with this.
I'll provide a link for it in
the description on this video
and on Khan Academy,
but the main idea is to get an intuition
for how a sampling
distribution is different
from just a traditional
probability distribution.
That in a sampling distribution,
you're taking samples from a population,
calculating some
statistic for that sample,
and what you're plotting in
the sampling distribution
are the various probabilities,
the various likelihoods,
of the outcomes for those
statistics in those samples.